بيصادف اليوم الثاني والعشرين من فبراير
مناسبه عزيزه على قلبي وقلوب كل السعوديين
وهي ذكرى يوم التاسيس قبل ثلاثه قرون اللي
تم الاحتفال فيه لاول مره العام الماضي
هاشتاقات يوم التاسيس يوم بدانا متصدره
منصه تويتر اللي احتفلت في يوم التاسيس مع
السعوديين على طريقتها الخاصه فعملت حركه
لكل منهم داخل السعوديه وهي انه لما
يعملوا لايك على اي تغريده يتغير شكل
القلب حق علامه اللايك لشعار يوم التاسيس
مثل مو شايفين امامكم واحتفالا بيوم
التاسيس البلد مليانه بمختلف مناطقها
ومدنها فعاليات ثقافيه فنيه شعبيه غير
العروض الجويه طبعا والالعاب الناريه
وبيتضمن يوم التاسيس فعاليات ثقافيه فنيه
ايوه مجموعه اخرى المزيد او المزيد المزيد
من الفعاليات ونحن بنتكلم طبعا على
الفعاليات في مختلف المدن نحن خلينا نحن
نروح للظهران تحديدا من اث هيكون معنا
الزميل عبد الرحمن العصيمي اهلا فيك معانا
عبد الرحمن
كل سنه وانت طيب وانت طيب وانت بالف صحه
وخير وسلامه يا رب اول شيء احكي لي عن انت
ايش لابس
انا اليوم متزين زي اجدادنا وابائنا لابس
الثوب المرودن اللي ذو الاكمام الطويله
ولابس طبعا الدقله ولابس المجند هذا الزي
الذي المقاتلين قديما في المعارك لانه في
يكون في جزء من الرصاص او الخنجر او ايضا
السلاح وايضا لابس العقال المقصب هذه
العقال اللي كان يلبسوا اجدادنا والملك
عبد العزيز مؤسس الدوله السعوديه الثالثه
فيصل لكن بعد السبعينات تقريبا بدا يندثر
ثم عاد اكثر فاكثر مع الاحتفالات بيوم
التاسيس منذ العام الماضي في نسخته الاولى
طبعا احنا في مركز اثراء زي ما انت شايفه
يعني الناس والازياء الجميله معنى هذه
السيده الجميله اللي لابسه زي الوطني
القديم طبعا فوق راسها السره الاسم الكريم
زينه زينه زينه عارفين عن لبسك لابسه
اليوم طبعا
اي نعم طبعا هذه هذه اسمها البقشه
وهذا ثوب النشل برقع وهذا زي الشرقيه انا
حبيت اليوم اني اطلع بزي حلو وجميل يمثلنا
ويمثل السعوديه الشرقيه
كل عام وانتم بخير طبعا انت اسمك على اسم
برديوسر البرنامج
برافو عليك يا عبد الرحمن فعلا هي انبسطت
قالت اوه في على اسمي
طبعا اكيد لازم دحين تلاقيني ساره والسنه
هذه دور زينه بالضبط لازم تلاقيني
يلا اسمي كريم دلال طيب عرفيني عن لبسك
انت اليوم ايش لابسه اهل الشرقيه اللي هو
الدراعه
والكف ذهب والبرقع
كل عام وانتم بخير طبعا ساره حنا اليوم
معنا شاعر
يعطيني قصيده عصماء الاسم الكريم زياد بن
محمد فرحان مرزوق الحربي ونعم يا زياد انت
قلت لي عندي قصيده يلا اتفضل
انا مسلم يا مديح بلادي لكن يا موطني
ماذا اقول فيكم اسقطوا راسي من جعل البلاد
منارات لا تظلموا ماذا اقوله فيك اعظم
قبله يا قبله جمعت غيرك يقسمك ماذا اقول
وسيدي سليمان قد ساد البلاد كما يستر
صح لسانك
ما شاء الله كل عام وانتم بخير طبعا خلنا
بنكمل الجوله ساره معنا ايضا هنا غزلان
ولدتها برضه لبسهم وزيهم الجميل هذا
تكلمي اليوم كيف شفتي الاحتفالات مبسوطه
هنا مره مبسوطه وش لابسه اليوم
لابسه لبس كثير لبس قديم كل عام وانتم
بخير ههه والله معنا ايضا هنا نفسي البس
هذا اللبس حلو طبعا
طبعا تعريف جميل وبسيط ومختصر لبس قديم
اختصرت
اليوم لبس اهل الجنوب ولا
اليوم والاجواء هنا في اثراء
جايه مع العائله ومع اخوانك
تنصحين الناس طبعا اكيد كل عام وانتم بخير
طبعا ايضا معنا هنا احدى
الجميل ايضا مع الريحان اللي على الشعر
الراس وايضا السله القديمه هذا زي اي
منطقه منطقه عسير هذا يمثل منطقه عسير كيف
شايف الاجواء اليوم الاحتفالات الناس كثير
مره يسالوني هذا يمثل اي منطقه وانا منها
وكذا قعدت ايامك جاهزين
في بعض جاهز من عند امي اخذنا عند جدتي
ههه
ساره يعني زي ما انت شايفه في استغلال
يعني
الامهات والجداد استغلال عظيمه اليوم لا
لا روعه روعه روعه
رائعه
كده واقفين مع بعض ولا هم دول اللي شفناهم
تكلمنا معاهم غزلان واصدقائها لا لا شوفي
هذه يا ساره شوفي هذه يا ساره تعالي تعالي
يا قلبي ايوه هذه الواحده حكايه صار شايفه
كيف شايف الخدود يا ساره
ايش اسمها
شو اسمها
استفسار اسمع بسمه مش ساره انا عارف انك
تدورين عن ساره بس ما في ساره اليوم لا
تحاولين يا ساره
طبعا بس كم عمرها ما شاء الله
طبعا يعني بسمه عمرها سنه جايه اليوم
محتفله مع اهلها لابسه اللبس الجميل هذا
يعني
اجواء رائعه صراحه بس
اجمل طفل اليوم في اثراء ولا لا ايش رايكم
متفقين معاي طبعا الجمهور كله صوتنا اليوم
رائعه انت يا عبد الرحمن قول لي كان في
اعجاب باللوك حقك اخذك وقت وانت بتجهز له
كمان ولا برضو اعاده تدوير طبعا انا لا
طبعا انت عارفه يا ساره انا يعني دايما
عندي معجبين
فاليوم في
اعجاب خاصه اذا لاحظت العجائب يعني زي ما
انت شايف الحين عندنا هنا
يعني في ناس مقيمين في السعوديه
فروم تايوان
سعودي تراديشنال دريسز
جميله وانيقه
بالضبط
يعني زي ما حتى المقيمين
ناس من اوكرانيا ايضا المتحده الامريكيه
وبريطانيا خاصه الموظفين الموجودين في
ارامكو المنطقه الشرقيه فكلهم جايين
يستمتعون ايضا بالاحتفالات
الفعاليات طيب شكرا لك صراحه طبعا بسمه
تفوز باللوك الرائعه وطبعا بشكرك جدا كان
معانا الزميل عبد الرحمن عشان ما تزعل
زينه
عبد الرحمن انت اليوم راح تتصل عليك زينه
وترسل لك هديه اكيد على العموم انا بشكرك
على الظهور معانا طبعا اليوم ويعطيك
العافيه وكل عام وانت
والسعوديه بالف الف خير كان معنا الزميل
عبد الرحمن